>> Tucker: IT’S OH FOXY SO DR. F
DAY OFF AND THROUGHOUT THE FIRST
PITCH OF THE NATIONALS GAME IN
WASHINGTON.
BUT ONCE DR. FAUCI THOUGHT HE
WAS OFF CAMERA, THE MASK CAME
OFF, LITERALLY.
YOU WANT TO SEE HYPOCRISY AND
ACTION?
LOOK AT THIS.
HERE HE IS SITTING WITHIN 6 FEET
OF OTHER PEOPLE IN A MOSTLY IN
THE STADIUM WITHOUT WEARING HIS
MASK.
HE WAS IMMEDIATELY CALLED ON
THIS BUT RATHER THAN COPPING TO
IT AND BEING HONEST, HE ACTED
LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE EMPOWERED TO
DO AND SCORNED ANYONE
CRITICIZING HIM WATCH.
>> I THINK THIS IS SORT OF
MISCHIEVOUS WITH THIS THING
GOING AROUND.
I HAD MY MASK AROUND MY CHAIN, I
HAD TAKEN IT DOWN, I WAS TOTALLY
DEHYDRATED END OF HIS DRINKING
WATER TRYING TO REHYDRATE
MYSELF.
AND BY THE WAY I WAS NEGATIVE
COVID LITERALLY THE DAY BEFORE
SO I GUESS PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE
THAT THING ABOUT IT, I WEAR A
MASK ALL THE TIME WHEN I’M
OUTSIDE, TO PULL IT DOWN TO TAKE
SOME SIPS OF WATER AND PUT IT
BACK UP AGAIN, I GUESS IF PEOPLE
WANT TO MAKE SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT, THEY CAN >> Tucker: IF
PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE A THING OF
IT, IF PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE A
FETISH OF MASK, LIGHTEN UP
AMERICA.
I’M SORRY, YOU ARE DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI AND YOU ARE ONE OF THE
REASONS OUR ECONOMY HAS GROUND
TO A FAULT.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE REASONS
PEOPLE ARE AS UNHAPPY AS THEY
HAVE EVER BEEN.
WERE YOU JUST LECTURING US ABOUT
WHY WE ARE IMMORAL IF WE DIDN’T
DO IT?
WE BET THAT DR. FAUCI WON’T HAVE
TO PAY THE THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE
THAT THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA IS
NOW IMPOSING ON CITIZENS WHO
DON’T WEAR MASKS IN PUBLIC.
HERE IS THE MAYOR OF WASHINGTON,
AIR QUOTES AROUND THAT ONE,
MURIEL BOWSER ANNOUNCING THE
POLICY.
WATCH.
>> I AM ALSO TODAY SIGNING A NEW
MAYOR’S ORDER ON MASKS AND
BASICALLY WHAT IT SAYS IS, IF
YOU LEAVE HOME, YOU SHOULD WEAR
A MASK.
THIS MEANS IF YOU ARE WAITING
FOR A BUS YOU MUST HAVE ON A
MASK.
IF YOU ARE ORDERING FOOD AT A
RESTAURANT, YOU MUST HAVE ON A
MASK.
IF YOU ARE SITTING IN A CUBICLE
IN AN OPEN OFFICE, YOU MUST HAVE
ON A MASK.
>> Tucker: UNTIL THE DAY
JOE BIDEN WINS THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, YOU,
MR. AND MRS. AMERICA, MUST WEAR
MASKS.
UNLESS YOU ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
WROTE THE MASK ORDINANCE IN
D.C., THE POLITICIANS, THEY
EXEMPTED THEMSELVES.
OH, BECAUSE THEY HAVE SUSPENDED
THE RULES OF SCIENCE BECAUSE
THEY ARE IN POWER AND YOU ARE
NOT.